[Music]
we used to play a lot of games when we
were kids um family games we were like a
norman rockwell painting
my favorite game and the one that i
think i excelled at was the most was
monopoly i was quite shrewd and i was
very like entrepreneurial and i left
am i trying to paint a better picture of
myself oh my god this is way too
flattering i'm going to correct the
record in a second
so anyway i think i was good at monopoly
and one game i was doing really well i
had hotels everywhere
i was kind of gloating too i was being
like a bad winner and i landed on a
community chest that was the real estate
tax where you have to pay
for all the properties you own
and i didn't have enough money it wiped
me out and i was so
upset i remember you going crazy you got
so upset you got so competitive and
angry that basically you didn't get your
way in monopoly so you got a ban you got
a lifetime this is a long time ago
i was in like 25 but also you got the
last laugh because you ended up buying
actual property
that
far exceeded i think anyone i know yeah
that's true you win you win like life
monopoly but i also got in sometimes
over my head with buying places that's
true
and then you have real life meltdowns
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life for short i'm
your host justin long get it life could
be a dream sweetheart
with me as always is my equally punny
brother christian but a much better
sport
um
wow you're still defensive better sport
about monopoly
maybe not about well also about pink i
was going to say no maybe you're a
better sport well let's be a little
honest about uh your temper i think it's
fair i think we're in an intimate place
right now i think we're in our we're in
our house right yeah we should be honest
about your temper you had a temper as a
kid my former temper
right you still you don't have much of a
temper anymore i will say but you had a
really big temper as a kid you were very
competitive i've worked on it you also
used to get really upset about your
report cards when you got a bad report
card right
yeah i remember you remember one time
you got a bad report card and you came
home and you you had it in your hand
that you had the paper report card in
your hand and you were just going around
to the like different parts of the house
slamming it on different walls
with your hands
remember it's so clearly i was so scared
you were like the tasmanian devil yeah i
would go berserk i was a very dramatic
kid and then i would get very emotional
there were many times i remember running
away or threatening that i was gonna run
away and then i didn't get the response
i wanted um so that made me more upset
so i pack up a big bag i'd make a big
show you know the cartoons like um wiley
coyote or bugs bunny they would always
pack like a
a little sack there was something very
pathetic about it and that you know if
you want to look pathetic to your
parents that that was a nice prop to
have anyway why are we talking about
anger and our anger issues as kids
mostly my anger is because i mean even
even your temper pales in comparison i
would say to our guests temper today ugh
pales pales yeah pale is more than one
way yes our guest is very pale and he is
a very large temper what a great
introduction he's gonna love this he's
also maybe the funniest person i've met
yes likewise our guest today is bill
burr who is yeah one of the best
comedians in the country uh the world
i'd say the universe he is uh
so funny and and actually is an
incredible actor too and i don't think
he gets the credit for that um he's been
in a bunch of movies uh the two of us
are on a show that bill created on
netflix called f is for family it's an
animated show bill plays the father of
this family in the early 1970s and i
play his son i play the oldest of his
kids this very angsty teenager named
kevin with a bad temper right yeah yeah
terrible temper and we talked a little
bit about this but it's one of the great
joys of my professional life is getting
to do scenes with bill where we're just
yelling at each other we just like
scream at each other because i'm i'm
almost always yelling or he's a teenager
he's a 14 15 year old so he's either
really
horny or angry
you tapped back into your monopoly days
yeah it didn't take much
um i did actually it's really fun to be
able to do that now in like a controlled
environment and uh
for for something positive yeah
um anyway he's he was kind enough to sit
down he also has uh a podcast that is
maybe our favorite podcast you don't
both have to have the same favorite
podcast uh it is definitely my favorite
podcast i would say it's the one podcast
that i
never miss an episode of that's true i
listen every single week you're a very
loyal follower i don't i don't listen as
much uh his podcast is called the monday
morning podcast and
there is no one better in my opinion
there's no one better
at
talking to himself and that's mostly
what his podcast is every once in a
while he has a guest or his his wife nia
comes on but it's mostly him just
ranting
and i don't think there's anyone better
at doing that and
it's weird i didn't i recently met him
for the first time and but it was
strange to meet him in person because
listening to his podcast
i feel like and i know you could say
this about other podcasts and
and this isn't uncommon necessarily but
i legitimately felt like i knew him i
know because i knew so much about him
and i was so familiar with him that it
seemed weird that i didn't know him well
i don't know him well i mean i don't
know him that outside just working on
that show and doing an animated show you
don't often get to be around the person
usually we record separately so and his
wife nia christian and i have worked
with christian i've done a bunch of
shorts that you can see on the other
cabin.com um but nia is in is very good
actress and uh she was kind enough to be
in some of those shorts and and they
have such a great relationship i love it
when she comes on the podcast because
they
are often antagonistic towards each
other but in a really fun loving way
they disagree a lot but it's so fun to
listen to how
they fight through that in a loving way
again and
yeah um it's funny we i
i think we've just gotten lucky in that
we've had a lot of guests on the show
who are in
really good relationships
you know yeah ones that are like kevin
bacon and keir sedgwick that's true and
kobe smulders they're like aspirational
relationships yeah um
you're in a good relationship i am yeah
uh i am not but i uh
well maybe what now that when uh
women hear that i i had a horrible
temper as a kid they're gonna love that
they're gonna they're gonna come up
knocking
um
anyway i i've always looked up to him
for that for his sense of humor and um
he has a great special
many great specials but his current one
that's out now is on netflix is called
paper tiger and it's
pretty brilliant
uh you should definitely watch that he's
got an incredible mind he's so quick uh
it was difficult to just keep up with
him um but it was fun to try so i hope
you enjoy my attempt at keeping up with
the great hilarious angry at times
bilper
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello again
[Music]
i love you taking off your sneak around
i don't know why i like mr rogers
um
you just held it up fred rogers stuff he
did that right he switched from he throw
dudes
oh that was the move yeah yeah that's
classic um you're such a good person
yeah almost to the point of being weird
and then i watched the documentary it
was like no this guy was just a good
person yeah you're like waiting for the
darkness that they understand because i
think meeting a truly good person is so
weird that they're sort of weird by
default yeah who was that guy who ran
for president ralph nader yes that
everybody blamed for the 2000 yeah yeah
which it really wasn't i think it was
that time when
was it al gore it was good they were
like hey you didn't laugh enough in the
last debate and the next debate he came
i was just like
[Laughter]
like
but not to but don't go howard dean yeah
go get you keep it in that yeah he
[ __ ] up he [ __ ] up but
that guy like i saw a documentary on him
one time and they would like how they
tried
everything
first of all they dug into his life with
howard nader yeah they tried everything
they dug into his life and the guy had
nothing yeah so then he'd go to this
grocery store or something so they
started sending beautiful women there
they're like hey ralph that's ralph
that's kind of a sexy name and he just
was just like yeah you know she's kind
of getting these kumquats and didn't
respond to that then they said gay guys
in no way that didn't work i saw the
documentary on him one time that didn't
work and they were like the [ __ ] guy
is asexual
guys they couldn't get him
and that's amazing
paper tiger your special on netflix is
is
brilliant and i texted you it's so funny
it's so good but it's also
i think it's important uh in terms of uh
being able to
say
what you think it's just
just how scary it is
it shows you yeah how
off the road this whole vetting thing
became that you had to like literally be
measured in saying hey i think somebody
in america should be able to say what
they want yeah yeah um
were you nervous were you had how has it
been received i mean i was definitely
like
already when it was coming out like just
when it comes out as a comic you just
you just can't go on social media for
like three days because
you're gonna get uh the chicken little
people you know the sky is falling yeah
acorn on the head thing
and they and i gotta be honest like
after like three four days
of thinking stuff like that it just kind
of struck me as funny like i've done
nothing wrong i just did my job i went
on there and i'm making people laugh and
this is the thing too is they don't get
to see
what i see when i see when i really when
i really get somebody laughing
like
and what i get out of that the crowd i
mean well it's a very like
fair thing that's going on in that like
like this you can make people laugh and
there's a certain level of laughing that
you can take somebody to where if you
get them to that level they're not
thinking about anything else in their
life in that moment other than what you
just said and how funny that is and
maybe oh my god am i going to be able to
catch my breath when you get that that's
like the
brass ring that you're reaching for that
laugh every joke every tag which is
impossible but when you get somebody
laughing like that
it just makes you feel so good yeah so
what you're doing is like this really
positive thing but like you know people
just kind of like
they spin it in such like a selfish
negative way i remember when i used to
watch patrice because patricia could
more than anybody ever saw could get
somebody to that level and i remember
you know he would have sort of that
choppy getting to what he was going to
say before he let you have it yeah and
sometimes the crowd figured out where he
was going and he would see people
already laughing and it would make him
laugh that's awesome and it was like um
watching him obviously perform was
incredible but watching him laughing
along with his crowd
legitimately yeah like they're live
everyone's enjoying the making him
laughter and you're just laughing you're
saying like this guy
this is all [ __ ] i could never say to
him like man phil shut the [ __ ] up oh
really but he would also know but like
the joy watching him that he would get
out of making somebody laugh which is a
[ __ ] great thing to do for somebody
yeah
okay uh
born outside of boston
duh the safe suburbs yes oh where where
newton or i was i lived on the north
shore when i was really young and then
grew up in the south shore we moved
around a little bit okay so how close is
that is for family then to your actual
childhood well it's an amalgam of of
every like the other show creator uh
co-creators show mike price great mike
price from the simpsons and then we have
all these amazing writers and you know
the interview process
was basically tell us some childhood
stories oh it's just like well mom made
an apple pie alright see you later just
like my brother used to hit me for no
[ __ ] reason all right let's
you move to the next round so it was
like this is a weird sort of thing where
they kind of act and i tend to believe
it too but i don't know if it's as
prevalent as people think that there's
this generation gap in like parenting um
with like you know it was tougher when i
was a kid now you guys blah blah yeah
like just
these writers i mean they're all you
know 15
20 years younger than me
in the writers room and they
had you know an older brother or a bully
or something like that i think it's just
now with social media maybe
it's just new ways to bully where it's
kind of like the mob the mob has new
scams now now that they're online
they're kind of doing like the uh well
sort of most of them went legit and got
into corporations because if you look at
a lot of the old school mob things
they're all just legalized well vegas
gambling now you can you can do the
sports book yeah like banking
there used to be laws on usury now there
isn't so banking is just legalized loan
sharking
uh the lottery is just the numbers sure
it's the way you you're talking about
how they used to control politicians
back in the day they would like
to take you out and now they just don't
give you as much air time on msnbc
i always said what's the difference
between a bank and a loan shark looks
like well bank will never break your
legs it's like well they don't have to
have the cops right the reason why a
loan shark had to was because what he do
you could you know enforce her hey buddy
it's not legal [ __ ] yourself oh yeah
there you go how about now all right
yeah yeah so you play the dad on f is
for family i just want to give people
some context and then i play the oldest
son this takes place in the early 70s
and um
i play a very i always say like i do
every line of mine is some version of
saying
stupid dildo yeah it's just there's a
lot of like yelling and
it's a really fun
kind of liberating thing to get to do um
but i always say there's nobody i'd
rather yell with than than you you're
just like a great person to get a good
person to yell
no but i like kevin because kevin is
refining is a very
sensitive kid yeah he's very creative
and he's not necessarily book smart
which i've i find a lot in this business
i just met this amazingly brilliant
musician slash pilot and i was talking
and i just i just you know one of those
people you're talking to it's like how
is all of that in your head yeah as
you're talking and then i just said just
out of curiosity how did you do in
school it was terrible oh that's
interesting it's like and i meet a lot
of people
like that in this business where it was
uh do you think that of yourself do you
i think that i definitely have did
terrible yeah i bet yeah but i just
would when it did mattered and right
when it counted i was like a field goal
kicker and i just pushed them all wise
i hooked it i hooked it
uh what kind of kid were you were you
interested in music i know you're a big
drummer you love to drum i love music
but i was i was always into just
screwing around making and i was into
sports i played sports uh
yeah i played baseball my dad kind of
saw the cte thing coming oh really i
signed up for football and i wanted to
play and he used to scream at my mom
every night going like christ the guy's
a toothless truck driver coaching the
goddamn team you're out there getting
hit in the head yeah so i quit
because of that i didn't want him to
because i knew he was upset yeah
and you know he's all misdirected when
you grow up in like a house of
volatility you learn how to like okay
this is what he's saying what does he
mean all right which is help me really
as a communicator
i'm like i'm getting a weird vibe off of
this guy he's being all friendly what
the [ __ ] is really going on right well
very you're very intuitive you're very
good at kind of what do you mean by that
no
well but what how close is he to friend
i'm my only friend of reference for him
i mean i met him briefly and he see he
didn't seem at all
the way
the picture that you paint of him or or
the version that i had in my head with
frank murphy and
um oh yeah no my not my dad it wasn't
like frank murphy it's it's a cartoon
where
we're exaggerating that's true it is a
good guy but there was like things he
did say i'll put you through that
[ __ ] wall and he also did say that
one time when he was outside and we were
trying not to laugh because he just sort
of pointed towards the woods it's like
is there a house on the other side do
you know a grizzly man
um but what it is was was he was
actually really a big softy uh-huh and
he wasn't gonna do stuff like that but
then like my mother was the one oh yeah
okay but he needed to instill some
degree of fear uh yeah it was all and it
worked like he came home oh [ __ ] dad's
home was comedy a thing you always
wanted to do when you were a kid was
that something that you
uh thought about doing oh yeah um i just
knew that i loved it yeah and i you know
i
fell into the thing that every person
does the first time they see a comedian
they're just like oh this guy must be
the greatest guy ever to hang out with
all he does is crack jokes all the time
he's always in a good mood you know yeah
yeah before you meet the cliched sad
clown thing yeah or the worst the jaded
comic who stopped writing 20 years ago
that's the hardest
thing to watch um terrifying to watch as
you're a comedian on the way up going
like how do i avoid oh god yeah you must
and you must see a lot of them i mean uh
not so much now because what happened
was you know so many people just ended
up being a journeyman well there's so
few uh out so there was like you're
right network yeah yeah it was a finite
amount of channels a finite amount of
shows what was the shot that comedians
had we're like they're like well if i if
i get to this was it being on conan was
it being back then it was uh a pilot
well i think way back
the beginning of my career it was like
you wanted to get on the tonight show if
you got on tonight's show and johnny but
then you had to have a good set and
johnny had to call you over to the couch
right that's why the older guys tell it
to me right because if you just if and
then he could he gave you the okay thing
that meant you were going to be back but
that was kind of like a
like a little bit of a
didn't quite like but if you called you
over to the couch and really liked you
that was like this big thing
and there's conflicting things some guys
say that you immediately started selling
all of these tickets but steve martin in
his amazing book uh was it born standing
up yes yeah he
he said like that's not the way it was
it was like you had to do it like 10 11
times and it was like hey don't did i go
to high school with you 15 times hey
you're that guy that does the thing
20 times then then you were like huh a
guy which i think makes more sense yeah
yeah it was just exposure well i've seen
somebody one time are you gonna remember
their name the next day at work it's
like yeah difficult thing especially
back then where you couldn't like record
it and freeze it and totally watch it
you saw it one time you had one time to
watch it one time to get it and then
maybe hope for a rerun so when when did
you start noticing that i mean at one
point well to finish
uh
what
by the time i started it was the end of
that and it was it was more like work
totally clean go to montreal do a set
get a deal turn your act into a sitcom
and you want to be on must-see tv nbc
because they were [ __ ] killing it it
was all it was i forget the lineups now
it was like friend
seinfeld friends like
just shoot me yep and then abc was like
ellen uh the tim allen show home
improvement
and then i forget what cbs was cbs was
sort of landing i think they had more
procedural shows and they weren't they
they were kind of missing the mark
and then fox was the young hip
the sims yeah the living killer
yeah yeah yeah uh tracy allman show uh
21 jump street yeah this is where the
young hit people are yeah so it was kind
of it was that and then the wb came in
and then somebody it was another network
too right around there so that was the
end and there was mad tv on fox 2. so
there were so was that that was the goal
to to that was the the that was that was
where the
the river was rushing right jumped in
that's where your representation would
steer you towards
like you know we'll get up there we'll
get you to montreal you get on new faces
you get a deal
and then you know your act is perfect
talk more about your dad they'll see the
show man they're going to see the show
and it was like
um that's one of the hardest things to
go through when you're
first coming up because you come into
this business just you don't know
anybody total hat in hand you're just so
happy that you people like you are
acknowledging you're funny i want to
represent you want to represent me oh my
god i can't believe i'm making a little
money and you want to represent me and
then they start telling you what to do
and you're looking to see what other
people are doing because now you got to
this new level and it's just like it
must be it's just it's like there's
there's nobody to help you other than to
talk to other comics like how do i
[ __ ] navigate this [ __ ] i used to
have like four hour long conversations
with patrice yeah where because patrice
was dealing you know with a lot of [ __ ]
where it was just like
he he could have been a sitcom like
they'd be like i remember congress to
say he even got the name like patrice
everything you're saying it it
must be why there's a lot of com um like
insecurity among comedians and and you
know that the movie funny people is all
about that how there's a lot of like
backstabbing and and yeah and it's not
necessarily like
backstab there's a few
there's always a few people like that
there's a few on off stage guys or
whatever but it's it's mostly what most
people are is you know they got their
issues but they're just grinding it out
and they're you know everybody can have
their moments of [ __ ] envy and
jealousy whatever but there's not like
like
you know for movies they always have to
ramp it up like yeah sinister the guy
with the black hat or whatever but i'm
also into like like all the
all the infighting between you know like
bobby lee and this guy you know who
stole who's bit and all this you know
this you hear those stories about the
comedy store and you know what's funny
is i work there and i don't even know
that story all i know about bobby lee is
that he's [ __ ] hilarious yeah he
likes to stir [ __ ] up
and he's incredible at improv and like
where the store is at right now
creatively is insane like i remember
when i moved out there in 2007
first night i went down i was in a
depression i was like oh my god what did
i just do i just moved back to la i said
i would never live out here again and
the comedy was nowhere near what it was
there was barely anybody there and then
it was just like how the [ __ ] am i going
to work out my [ __ ] out here and then
rogan got kicked out of the club oh yeah
which was another one brutal yeah it was
brutal because and then he was the
fanciest thing right and then he wasn't
there and that was this massive [ __ ]
voi like
like you see what he's doing now like
like to put that on the
not even on the bench to just [ __ ]
say you can't come down that was [ __ ]
brutal but then i saw this guy al
madrigal oh sure and i was just like oh
[ __ ] this guy's funny
this guy's not saying those other people
weren't funny that's just like yeah i
wonder what that was it was like they
were literally going to work out in a
gym and they sat down to bench press and
all that was one uh plate to stick on
one side and they were just trying to
[ __ ] it was an impossible situation
weird i wonder why and
it's just because comedy has always gone
through these ebbs and flows of like
it's this cool thing this is awesome
this is incredible it's a great dude i'm
getting sick of this and it just goes
back down again and how much that is
dictated by the whatever the cultural uh
more
it goes by how much
they they put it on tv oh yeah and the
only thing that's saving us now i think
from another like basically stand-up
comedian housing bubble
eve despite the fact of how many [ __ ]
the sheer amount of specials that are
out there
is that that exists with everything
there are a million cop shows there's a
million behind the scenes
prison things there's a million
documentaries there's a million
everything so it levels it out right so
that it doesn't make it harder to
sustain a level of uh
i think it's harder now
back in the day i think it was easier if
you had a killer special to stand out
to have a special that maybe people
talked about for a couple of weeks and
which got you more fans
now it's it's supplanted by the next
thing trying to cut through
the white noise of all of this [ __ ] to
try to have a podcast that people will
find and listen to it's one of those
things where
you know what you always wanted total
artistic freedom but then everybody has
it
and everybody's grabbing microphones
it's like yeah how do i
i joined the club well the thing is is i
was talking to a comic older than me and
he just said listen he goes the cream
always rises to the top i know it's a
cliche people
really
recognize
if they're watching something that it
seemed like somebody took their time on
it and they care about it and it's
quality you've been doing the podcast
for what 10 year longer 12 12 jesus it's
interesting sometime to hear you now how
much you've changed because you you'll
you'll play on the thursday when you
play an older one uh
where's your comfort level with it now
now is it just like you're just hanging
out by yourself you do it usually by
yourself no it's kind of it got it's
been like that way for a while yeah um
no i just yawned there because i didn't
get enough sleep last night i know
you're a sensitive actor and you're
going to sit here and be like what does
that mean he doesn't like my questions
moving on do i need to wrap it up
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello again
we'll meet again
[Music]
why aren't you drinking for a year
that's incredible i'm not drinking just
because it got it got too out of hand i
have the time
yeah you look good to be a drunk and i
just you know but i also got into
bourbons and stuff yeah i said ooh this
one here
so i became pretend it's a hobby i
became the connoisseur drunk right yeah
yeah so it's classier and it was like
you know i didn't know how to
deal with some of the new stresses in my
life so i was using i was using it as
that and i was drinking alone and i
loved it yeah i would come home
my wife would be asleep i miss it still
and i would come home and i would get a
nice big ice cube i'm literally
mouth-watering now and i would take care
of your flush and my rule was
at first i know i would i would i would
you know i was really into reading the
whole thing like well you don't want the
ice cube to drip into the bourbon too
much because you're changing the flavor
it's like those people who like light a
cuban cigar with a little cedar [ __ ]
thing you know because you know what the
chemicals from the lighter and i was
really getting into the all of these the
more knowledge you have the more you can
disguise that your shit's a little out
of control yeah and that basically you
know i took a tour of the oreo cookie
factory and that they have this is the
amount this is how they put the sugar in
it's just like buddy as you're just
consuming a whole shave of them yeah and
your [ __ ] sugars off the rails it's
just like dude you're becoming a fat
[ __ ] because i'm not like an alkie
i'm not an alkie but i'm definitely a
guy like when i
what is made me successful could also
take me out because when i get into [ __ ]
yeah i get into [ __ ] it's like oh my god
i like bourbon
let me [ __ ] get into the department
[ __ ] whoa yeah whoa
i didn't have a problem then it became i
had to fill it up over just over the the
the ice cube
i used to call them because my wife
would give me [ __ ] like you know how
many times did i i had one drink she
goes it was like this [ __ ] big and
i'd be it's a home poor
but she's cool so she was all right
then one became two and then two became
three and i was like you know and then i
became a dad and then i was like
like legally shit-faced
yeah it must be this was my thing
this was my thing
i would i would come home
after doing stand-up i had a great
[ __ ] time
and i had these i actually bought these
glasses that this guy makes down in el
segundo i don't know if he still makes
them
in there and they were all this is when
i really got into it they were all made
out of glass okay the whole glass
including the ice cube it looked like an
ice cube but that was also glass and
then you took the glass and you put it
in the freezer so then when you took it
out you poured your booze in there and
it got chilled and you had this thing
that was essentially working like an ice
cube
but there was no water so you were
getting this straight it wasn't diluting
anything straight booze and it was
chilled yeah and my thing was i would
pour it up and over that glass thing
that looked like an ice cube and i would
drink three of them and i would watch
like three episodes of peter gunn or
maybe like 77 sunset strip and it was
like all old school tv so i didn't have
to deal with global warming or any of
this people screaming
about trump or [ __ ] hillary yeah and
i would just sit there and i would watch
this [ __ ] and everybody in the shows i
was watching was drinking and smoking
they wanted to kiss a woman get
you know these big [ __ ] gas-guzzling
cars
there was no ramifications to any of the
behavior the golden era and it made me
feel like uh yeah man i was born in the
wrong era man you know
that's always great to to analyze
yourself with nobody else yeah you know
and you just wow i'm liking all these
answers yeah compared to and you're
comparing yourself to like movie stars
like um
and it also must be weird to be at all
the few times i've been like
stoned or slightly drunk around like
i don't do it often but if i am around a
kid there's always something a little
weird about that but i can only imagine
because you're a well-adjusted person
there's a thing that you just can't like
uh
because i knew what was gonna happen was
eventually she was going to be old
enough to be awake when i was doing that
and i was going to normalize that sort
of behavior
and then just like yeah whatever my dad
drank you know blah blah blah so i try
you know
i try to
shield her from a lot of my problems
instead of trying to work out well i
like that you say that about parents
like about that we're all just we have
to leave leave our childhoods behind we
got to let go of the childhoods we can't
like because it doesn't exist
it's in your head right right so that
was a really sort of
great moment i had with my wife at one
point i was just like you know what i
[ __ ] realize it's like none of our
our childhoods don't exist anymore yeah
you're not this person you're not that
person you're you
and i'm me
and our kid is us right
and with her own thing sure she's wrong
so whatever the [ __ ] happened to you
when you were four what happened to me
when i was six that we're still hanging
on to right
it's not it's not in any way gonna
affect her unless we're still hanging on
to this [ __ ] right but you see it all
the time with parents it's hard it's
hard because you love them so much and
then you don't want to pass it on to
them and then what it is is it trying to
stop one issue you create this other
issue right that's right you know
through overbearing over controlling
sort of yeah trying too hard yeah
leaning the other way what's the thing
that you do want to really pass on to
her that you're like i'd be disappointed
if she didn't get this from me or get
this from from nia
um that you're going to be all right
that all these people the all there's
going to be all these people that are
going to sell you [ __ ] out of fear
everything from a car so you need two
years of a language
and all of this type of stuff like i
wish i could go back and it's just
literally
listen to your gut do what you want to
do and just know that so much [ __ ] that
people are gonna say to you in life
it's their reaction to this thing that
they're afraid you're gonna do right and
if you listen to them
i mean i can't imagine how many
incredible guitarists are working at
home depot or how many hilarious people
are like you know driving a truck or
something like that and they wanted to
do something and they just weren't
surrounded by the right people because i
wasn't strong enough to do this and i
just when i really look back the luck
that i had of falling into this
and how i i somehow well there must have
been right right right as i almost went
off the cliff and i wouldn't have done
it this person came into my life i mean
there is a way to where you can then
look back
and everything means something was that
exactly those like you said earlier
those are the things you remember yeah
i don't know
but there's definitely things where i i
just look like uh i just did a gig when
i was in vegas and i and i i still have
that thing thank god i said to my wife i
was just like can you [ __ ] believe
this is
our life like i can't believe that i'm
gonna go downstairs and get to act like
an idiot for an hour yeah it's the best
how [ __ ] hot awesome is this yeah
yeah
you can hear that in your podcast a
listener of your podcast i can i can
feel when you have a good show when
you've come back from a tour when you've
i really you were talking about the
middle part of europe how those state
like hungary
how well those shows were yeah budapest
i was on stage going i would [ __ ] do
a special here yeah and i was just like
i [ __ ] let's just this is yeah but
that's infectious you can hear that and
and to have that joy and i'm sure we've
both met people who are at yeah
warsaw budapest vienna they were all
just like i was just kept calling it the
midwest of europe yeah yeah if you stay
out of a defensive mindset and you just
get into the different vibes of each
country you can really have fun with it
and just talk to them i mean like
estonia uh lafayette when you get to
there like do you know that you ever
just meet somebody where it's like
they're not trying to make you not
comfortable they're sure of themselves
yeah and you're trying to tell them
something and they're not gonna laugh
unless it's funny
and they're not gonna buy it unless
unless you sell it to him oh i'm
terrible around
he's not doing anything to me why am i
so uncomfortable around this person
and uh i always thought there was a
power move you know those people who
kind of like wait you out you know what
it's a test of you yeah is what it is
and what you have to do what i always do
is i find the comedy in it
so the comedy in it is like wow i am so
[ __ ] uncomfortable with this guy so
you know what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
[ __ ] overly
commit to this
and i'm just gonna i'm gonna go even i
don't know how to do that necessarily in
a pitch because in defiance there's a
thing with defiance there's there's a
self-esteem to it but you gotta make
sure you don't punch through to [ __ ]
self-sabotage yeah so let the anger show
or any sort of frustration show yeah
where i had a period in my life where i
was so angry everything i said sounded
angry yeah i had this audition for this
show gregory heinz breast her soul
was going to do a sitcom and i had this
audition for it
and it was one of those things where
they were really far behind and right
before i was going to go in
they went to lunch
so then it was another half hour and
they ate or whatever just festival no no
but i wasn't mad i was nervous
because i was going to producers which
used to scare the [ __ ] out of me back in
the day so i was like
so i came in i was like bill and i knew
i was introverted and i knew i was angry
and i and i was like you got to say
something social
so they see you're a good guy and maybe
you can book this
and i came in there but everything i
said sounded angry
i didn't know that so i came walking in
they go hey they're like bill how are
you doing i'm like great how was lunch
that's how i said it but in my head i
was like great how was your lunch but
that's not how i said it
it was great how was lunch
and then they just said they're like
oh no i mean we just we got behind we're
sorry and then i was like oh no no
i don't need it like that and then they
go all right let's do the scene and this
guy taps and i look over and it's
gregory hines oh god because he was so
into the show
and such a pro that he didn't skip the
auditions he wanted to see if he vibed
with somebody oh my god and i went and
just was like
and he was all amazing i remember he was
hitting me with the sides like come on
man so casual let's be playful let's
play yeah let's play and i was like
that's the worst and just drove home in
my 88 honda accord just like [ __ ]
[ __ ]
window down [ __ ]
the thing was as i'd watched gregory my
whole life yeah so just that one blip
was just something that like it was more
like those moments in life i don't know
why come back to me when i'm in the
shower
i don't know why and i'll be in the
shower
and then when i hear them i try to shout
them out of my brain when i think of
them and i'll just be like watching all
songs i just picture hey how was lunch
and i see gregory hines and i just in
the shower just really go like
[Laughter]
are you all right you're right oh no i
just got it i got a charlie horse
i don't know why i don't just say are
you thinking about gregory hines again
yeah i was thinking about this time i
bombed an audition with gregory heinz
well yeah it's just you know what's
funny is there's it doesn't happen as
much but it comes from a place of
self-hatred yeah where i i hate myself
for that well you told such you i i
having listened to your show for a while
you have i think gotten
you know a lot better about letting
things go you've talked about that
you're really open about it but
you had a really funny thing happen to
you when you went to see to kill a
mockingbird um
there was a guy sitting a few rows
behind you
and it was it made us chris and i we
were listening to it it made us laugh so
hard because it's just it's such a small
thing like that what did i say that he
said it was so funny it was um
it's so it's soda pop in there like it
was it was the the moment where uh the
town drunk is sodapop yeah it's revealed
like he figured it out yes and then
another thing that you got the the
[ __ ] guy with the mental issues who
never speaks the whole time right before
he speaks he goes
say something yeah like like he was some
miracle he was like this [ __ ] yeah
ghost whisperer of a [ __ ]
people who haven't talked any years so
bill's watching his killing mockingbird
a guy was behind just it's basically
just like spoiler is spoiling the show
and he's clearly
read it or seen it and knew what was
coming and there's this running thing
where like the town drunk it's revealed
that he he actually is
it's also a move it's also a story that
has been around long and this guy's been
alive
and he's acting like it just came out
and he reads people so well
yeah but it's it made me laugh so hard
when you were like god i wish i wish i
had the balls to just turn around and
stare at him for the rest of the play
yeah and just look like make him that
uncomfortable make him but you know what
it is now now i actually
i i wish that i
could hang out with them
because yeah what you could as an uh
getting some acting roles now what you
could take from that guy yeah these
weren't secure just trying to see where
does it come from yeah totally how does
he do it and then just set him up to see
if he'll do it again
yeah it's in a different way and just
and then and then try different
reactions to it yeah to see how it does
it fill them up does it deflate him
how does he hold himself yeah like
that's the type of [ __ ] that is just
like uh like i don't know the more i
don't know the more i am the more i've
gotten into your amazing world of acting
which i think is one of the hardest
[ __ ] things to do well
it's one of the it's weirdest things one
of the easiest things to fake yeah
to just like like because there's so
many people it's just like uh oh do you
see so and so you know he's he [ __ ]
drives a truck he was great in that
movie it's like he was playing a truck
driver yeah all you had to do was just
memorize the [ __ ] lines and make them
sound believable well that's what i
think about i mean like yeah
it's i got to send this to you but
rockwell sent me a video of alan because
we both my first thing i did was with
alan rickman and
like a pretty consistent presence in my
life throughout the year someone i loved
and really like admired and i'll send it
to you this video of alan rickman
talking about acting he's like i'm not
going to do i can't do the impression
but he's like basically it confounds
he's like it confounds me that when
people
go over their lines the night before and
in the mirror and he's like all you want
to do is get to a point where you can
listen to somebody and be present to
somebody else and the way he says i'm
not i'm not doing it justice but he did
a little more than well that's right
he's being like super humble dude that
guy that guy could be
like
he was amazing in die hard which that
like that role
i know that movie made bruce willis a
star yeah and i i know and i love bruce
and all his movies but like that made me
a fan of his and i would just watch
everything he did even the face he made
when he fell yeah you know how they did
that with like a green screen how you
saw like oh my god this is the end it's
true to do a scene like that you got to
do a little bit more than just be
present to your fellow actors and like
yeah i was just listening to bruce
saying i'm going to throw you out this
window
yeah i really believed it
uh when people annoy you when things
like that happen because i think that's
one of the reasons i relate to your
comedy and i love your show they're how
do you let go of things like that i mean
i guess in the shower but how how do you
how long does it take for you to get
over i don't know what happened like i
was a really like you know angry
negative person and i just sort of
chipped away at it i think when people
watch my act they think probably think i
still am but i'm not i'm a really
i can find the daylight yeah i mean i
think that's just something
doing the road how depressing it can be
and lonely and everything it's just like
i had to like okay
okay i can sit in this
or i can try and get something out of
this day like okay i'm in [ __ ] denver
like what do people do here and i
started with sporting events
outlets you'd find out yeah i would just
yeah restaurants or i'd find a rehearsal
space where i could just jam on some
drums for like an hour yeah something
and now nia comes with you sometimes
before if you go to like like when you
went to ireland doesn't yeah if i go to
a cool place yeah he's all about
supporting me he's not coming to wichita
i just feel like you've been lonely
lately and i feel like rome would be a
good place for us to reconnect
uh no she's no dummy i remember and it's
not like she became this person she was
always that person because i remember
when i was dating her a long time ago
which new york is always so lonely when
i'm not when i'm not here with her
because it's just you know like tearing
down everything but like i still oh i
was in there you know there's a bar
where i remember
like our second date i remember when i i
um
walked into the bar uh she was sitting
at the bar and she had this white shirt
on this button-down shirt and she just
she looked radiant and i remember uh and
of course she [ __ ] she took it to the
dry cleaner and they lost it it's like
my favorite shirt that she had because
that was like the first time i was just
like you know i already felt something
the second time who is this person and
every time i walk by that bar i haven't
even been in it i won't go in it unless
she's there right so like uh i walk by
and every time i walk by i just picture
her looking over her shoulder smiling
when i walked in still this day so
that's cool um i don't remember the
question that's so vividly remembering
that so
so when i was with her i remember
early on i was doing um i had a new
year's date and i was and i was doing
kickers
in livonia michigan
it's a great kick yeah but i was just
like hey you want to go to uh you want
to hang with me new year's i've got a
gig and she's like where's it at i go
livonia michigan
she goes livonia michigan i go yeah you
want to go she goes
now and i laughed i go what she goes i'm
not leaving new york city
it's just like bill i love you and i
would love to have a kiss of the
countdown but like i'm not having
livonia michigan that's my backdrop and
i was just like i mean i gotta respect
that no that's such an attractive
quality but just that honesty well
that's why it's so compelling listening
to you guys talk on the podcast because
you're just so honest and you hold your
ground and okay and you know you'll
you'll that can lead to some epic fights
somewhere yeah yeah yeah no i've
standing your ground can really lead to
at some point it's like all right will
you give i mean like you listen to it i
mean that's that's the there's some i
have i know i go i go through streaks of
giving and then i have streaks of like
dying on every hill and then i just have
i'm going for a walk i've
i just can't seem to like and all of it
is is trying not to be the guy who dies
on every hill yeah so i know you guys
got into a thing about the m m store
she's like why do you keep saying it's
changed so much new york's changed so
much because because it has she's just
giving me [ __ ]
100 has
yeah but i remember taking a bus getting
off at the port authority and what the
[ __ ] i saw either this looked like a
giant [ __ ] jerk off yeah but if shop
if i better find renee i would say yeah
but that was back in the 90s when you
first got here we left in 2007. i think
that was her point yeah but already
started changing but even since 2007.
but even since 2007 i was just changed
yeah
yeah i'm sorry
yeah dude are you kidding me it looks
like a [ __ ] bed bath beyond that's
true yeah times squares is they just
they're just leveling yeah everything
i'm not saying it's good or bad but like
dude the skyline do you recognize the
skyline from like if you looked at it
from 10 years ago and those tall super
skinny things that are killing central
park
and also when i used to date neon i'd go
up to see her in harlem and i would go
up there after my shows and i'd get off
the [ __ ] subway and you had to walk
down the middle of the street yeah yeah
because people would jump out and grab
you like it was [ __ ] escape from new
york yeah
yeah that was 2004. oh okay yeah you go
up there now there's some white guy with
like a cupcake shop life could be a
dream sweetheart
[Music]
do you think about that now i like
afterlife and do you were you ready you
were raised catholic yeah and i was very
i went every single week and i totally
believed it and everything and then
as i got older and i just sort of
understood
that uh there was just sort of one point
of view
was sort of put on me yeah
and and then like all of the [ __ ] that
they were saying didn't make any sense
yeah they say oh god loves everybody
and all this type of [ __ ] but like
you just saw the racism and then they
had things about gay people and then
that what all religions have is this
sort of thing god loves us he loves
everybody but he loves us the most yeah
and we're right
well once i find out i just sort of
realized that there was an element of
[ __ ] to all religions
i then also got kind of come to a point
of like well then because of their
[ __ ] maybe they took something away
from me
the spirituality thing this thing that
you feel this connection that you feel
like you know i'm telling when you
connect with somebody you're making them
laugh you're making them you're making
them feel so good that they make you
feel good yeah and that feeling of when
you do something bad and you just you
feel bad oh god i'm a piece of [ __ ] i
hate myself versus how you feel when you
there's definitely a there's there's
definitely a right and wrong
out there yeah and i saw this thing one
time on this thing fractal geometry now
i do not i'm not good at methanol and
this guy [ __ ] blew my mind where this
guy
was flying in an airplane and he was
looking down and he saw repeated
patterns
where i would just look out and be like
all right we're over the desert you know
we're getting close to he saw repeated
patterns
and he
came just started analyzing nature
and literally like a tree the shape of
the tree the trunk the branches and all
that he would then go look at the leaf
it's the same shape
going into this the dna of this tree and
then somehow it all came down to the
number three
that everything was a thing of threes
and he would show it i mean it was like
some [ __ ] rain man
and i started reading more about this
and how like there's these scientists
where a lot of their trajectory was
because they were so logical that like
you know organized religion was like
santa claus for adults and then they
would just keep getting answers and
answers and answers until they would
just get to something so [ __ ]
mind-boggling
that you couldn't comprehend it yeah
that it would actually send them back to
believing that there was something else
something that created that order oh
yeah and then like meditating where you
can you can get to the point where you
start to feel like you're leaving your
body and floating like this definitely
so now i'm to a place now
where
i feel like if there's something none of
us know what it is and there's a big
business on
of of acting like you know what it is
from a tarot card reader right to an
organized religion so i feel like those
people took something from all of us
yeah by trying to organize and turn this
you know your spirituality if i do
something good i feel good if i do
something bad like they took that from
everybody yeah and turned it into this
ponzi scheme i now have this weird view
of i now don't know what happens but i
feel like
collectively as human beings we've we've
gone the walmart route is always with it
yeah turned it into some sort of
business thing and that something has
been taken from all of us including the
people that were profit off of it so uh
but you still have moments you feel so i
i i have no answers yeah
all right i don't know um all right
these are really quick uh when you text
what's your most commonly used emoji
would you say somebody asked me that
today thumbs up thumbs down oh really
thumbs up thumbs down that's it i'm
kidding that's just the perfect thing
simple yeah yeah and we're gonna eat
tonight at eight thumbs up
did you see what so-and-so said thumbs
down yeah okay
if you could be a professional athlete
what sport would you play
i actually i think i'd be a hockey
player
and i would want to be that guy i would
want to be like the enforcer
no but the guy who could also score 50
goals he could beat the [ __ ] out of you
or score goals
you know where the captains see you'd
want to be like those guys are like
heroes if you could have one snack food
for the rest of your life what's your
go-to snack food
oh can i get a sugar and assault oh yeah
yeah
uh
i'd say oreo cookies uh-huh
and this is a
fritos yeah with pringles there was a
sort of a salt quarterback controversy
yeah
yeah pringles could maybe take the
fritos i i really enjoy uh that's fine
we're just talking about it i love but
frito is on my uh that's my [ __ ]
is you know that takes me like there's a
line in the sand there's with that sort
of junk food like after me was the
dorito generation dorito and pepsi yeah
when they they tried to brand my
generation the pepsi generation it's
like no we're not what was your what's
coke oh okay coke that's like um i
thought they came around that's like
gray goose versus belvedere vodka oh
really like grey goose is so [ __ ]
smooth it's like but and and pepsi
sweeter
i always needed that like i want to feel
like i'm doing this yeah you know what i
mean so like i like booze that has more
of a bite to it it's just a different
product bourbon right you look better
yeah like coke when you take drink coke
you know it takes rust off of metal you
can feed it yeah when you drink pepsi
you're like i don't know this is maybe
this might be healthy yeah you can feel
your enamel your teeth enamel but i also
and i and i am uh and root beer although
i've drank so much of it lately because
in the last year because i i stopped
drinking really clues
that uh i've almost now ruined root beer
i can't i need to take a break from it
i'm surprised to be such a special thing
because first of all not a lot of people
have it yeah it's a real old man thing
yeah you got to be like 50 or older to
be a root beer guy i love i love root
beer but you're so weight you you're
pretty pretty like weight conscious you
were conscious that you were eating
right and you were no but i eat really
well now i eat really well and i don't
[ __ ] drink i smoke too many cigars
god that's amazing uh you don't smoke we
you know smoke weed uh depends on who
i'm around it's like if
they're around and i i just had like a
[ __ ] bad couple of days or something
like that but like i i don't like it
because
you know that's another real it's a real
novice sort of industry now yeah while
it's totally changed and it's
everybody's just like okay just take you
know bite a little corner of this and
you're just gonna feel good and all of a
sudden you just you just thought whoa
whoa like how high is this gonna go the
next day you're like dude what the [ __ ]
and then always like dude i didn't say
it
yeah i told you to eat it's like no you
didn't you don't know what you have yeah
and there's all these people who are
getting into [ __ ] the weed business
who aren't real true pot smokers yeah
they're just going because they're
seeing like oh this is an entrepreneur
this is a boom yeah oh comedy's big i'm
going to open a comedy club
i don't even know who jerry lewis is
right yeah yeah so i i there's a weird
there's a real
um
and then there's also i think it's so
for the world with
that it's it's actually like all those
properties where you know it makes you
feel good and you have to really watch
out like i feel like it's almost like
buying meat
where it was was this from a cow that
ate another cow
is this grass-fed i feel like weed is
getting like that where
um
there's probably a pressure
to have like the most potent yeah type
of thing and now micromanagement yeah
now once you've got like actual like uh
mr white's working on it they're gonna
make some of the the blue weed
and we don't know it's like vaping like
who knows what's going on
is that stuff good is it bad is this
people pissed that they took a big
uh a big chunk of the smoker market and
that's just [ __ ] like they did with
the suzuki samurai
and they said oh it tips over and kids
burned to death and you found out later
that came from uh oh no chrysler yeah
because they made the jeep and it was
kicking the [ __ ] out of him it was a
cheap fun jeep oh my god it's not easy
to say cheap fun cheese cheap fun jeep
uh what's your favorite movie of all
time i don't know that i have one um
because there's too many good ones but i
will tell you as far as the
movies that i watched and the actors
that i missed yeah
would be
you know i grew up i watched all those
cowboy the charles bronson
lee marvin yeah
um everybody in magnificent seven
um oh yeah yeah clint eastwood uh
kelly's heroes was a great one for me
yeah i loved uh see that reminds me of
episode family i mean that's what bridge
and the river quiet well that would be
the the frank stuff that is like me like
my dad loved all those movies too but i
did telly savalas um i just liked and
what was great about those actors back
then
when they were playing tough guys
because so so many of them were like we
were actually war vets like like lee
marvin his and i read some one time like
i think almost all of his platoon got
knocked out except for him and he got
shot oh my god so like when he was
playing like dirty dozen a tough guy
yeah this guy is legit like this guy
like
[ __ ]
went to war and was not you know in the
back
you know yeah potatoes this guy was up
front shooting a [ __ ] gun and god and
bronson like he [ __ ] came here he was
pulling he was like [ __ ] mine and
[ __ ] and when he was growing up like the
axis powers were sweeping through his
country and the fallout of all of that
james coburn all these yeah
these were like real that's why well
jack palin's why they were like
effortlessly tough
but as far as like favorite movies i
would say like
in the 80s one of my favorite movies was
midnight run i mean that's just such a
great like like a comedy those odd
couples
yeah yeah yeah but i'll tell you my
favorite movie in forever was once upon
a time in hollywood oh which i i saw it
twice and i i that's great it's just
like the first time i saw it like i just
so taking in oh my god look at that card
oh where's that where's that is that los
vilas is that yeah
so i was looking at the locations and
then brad pitt was just like oh that's
the guy i want to be it took me the
second time to realize that i saw
leonardo dicaprio's greatest performance
yeah he's just incredible and i don't
want to ruin it for anybody but i could
talk to you for four hours yeah and i've
only seen it twice i never thought i'd
say like i witnessed one of the best
performances i've ever seen of somebody
just being hungover i mean there's a
whole scene where he's just hung over
and he's like trying to de-puff his face
and itself and that old school way where
you stick your face in the ice yes it's
so good
you know paul newman used to do that
every morning oh no kidding he would
fill his sync up with ice
and just just for aging because there
was no botox or anything back then oh my
god and and what you do is you just
stick your face in it take it out and
you just do that for a little while and
it's it's actually it's probably really
good for you well it worked i always ask
who everyone's favorite muppet is but i
i i hesitate to ask you so hard um
i can tell you my one of my favorite
sketch is the one with all the monsters
some of us are here oh uh such a funny
yeah all of them all the hairy ones and
all this yeah yeah yeah some of the hair
sounded scary
and then that guy that it was like
butter
yeah it was the one with the horns going
up and there was
going down yeah that little baseline
band but they did two with that guy and
it was just one of the things like this
guy should have been a bigger star
muppet
um so i liked all of that i loved grover
grover had such a good heart i loved
ernie because ernie was silly
yeah and it's funny when the funny i
liked all the happy ones and i'm really
more oscar the grouch
but i i liked i liked uh
i liked all of it yeah i mean i was a
real little kid i used to like when it
was uh
grover sang a song with this little like
boy muppet it was g grover
g like letter g and g george i used to
watch that as a little kid it would
almost make me cry yeah
are you just all young and innocent yeah
[ __ ] yeah
no that was a huge thing and i it was
got my my daughter wasn't into it at
first and now i got her into it and um
that's gonna be one of the best parts
about being it's changed a lot and i
have to admit elmo is sort of the uh
what's that star wars character that
everybody hates oh jar jar elmo annoys
me a little bit elmo's a little elmo's
always like you know there's always up
there yeah yeah uh
a little too positive it's and it's a
difficult voice to listen to yeah
yeah it's always exciting oh my god i
was getting okay elmo
cookie monster was just such like
big hearted awesome [ __ ] dude and
then also just so zen
c is for cookie that's good enough for
me it's one of those zenith things
that's true it's just [ __ ] awesome
yeah if you could be one age for the
rest of your life what would you pick
physically
well if i could be one age just in
general be this age yeah if i could be
any age again
well what's once you become a parent it
sucks because then my kid's not going to
be there right so if we take the kid out
of there just selfish bill living in my
own [ __ ] world
i'd be
like 1920
again working at this place corporate
software where i i worked in this um
i worked in a warehouse yes loading and
unloading trucks yeah before
things really carried any sort of weight
i was still living at home the stakes
weren't that high yeah and it was just
like everything was still [ __ ] new
when it was possible
yeah and i'm not saying like different
things become like that is replaced when
you get older and you have kids yeah and
like you know watching my daughter learn
how to ride a tricycle was it was was
[ __ ] you know
it was pretty amazing beetles were
stones
i can't make that decision okay and
especially i definitely have to stick up
for the beatles because there's a lot of
people younger like people now just like
you know what happens is
when there's you're as great as they are
everybody steals from you so then when
people go back and watch it they like it
just doesn't have the impact yeah yeah
you got to go back and just immerse
yourself into what was going on
when they put those records out how much
they influence yeah and i i just and
then what i loved what i love about the
rolling stones
is like
they have like that you know where the
beatles were like we're not playing
anymore live shows where i feel like
they had that need and that hunger yeah
they had to have that rush well that
feeling that you're talking about rush
from the audience when you're connecting
with an audience like that yeah
it's like a sickness yeah but if applied
properly which they did
is uh incredible like what i love about
watching keith when he plays a chord
when he lifts his shoulders up and he
makes that face it's it's not that's not
an act it's not effective you're
watching what it makes them feel like
yeah totally yeah i remember a buddy of
mine got like front row tickets like an
89 the one and only time i saw him on
the steel wheels tour and he was so
close and he was just oh dude he goes
keith was just whacked out on something
and then you read years later it's like
no he didn't do he hasn't done drugs
since like the 70s you know have a drink
here or whatever but like
it was just like what you were seeing
was a guy experiencing euphoria doing
what he loved to do totally and what you
were doing it was reading you know star
magazine and [ __ ] right you didn't
understand i saw one of the great things
i ever heard keith richards say as far
as like his passion he was talking about
how much he loved guitar
he goes
he was talking about opening a
a guitar case and that smell uh he goes
you know his bro oh he goes that smell
he goes he said you just want to crawl
in and close the lid and i was just like
he's like it's like dude this is just
coursing through his veins totally so um
i got that just any anybody like that is
like addicted to what they do to that
level it's like oh my god i got a
[ __ ] bruce springsteen i felt that
way but when i saw yeah when i could see
the the details of his face and how
yeah immersive you know i did a gig one
time in ireland
and uh
this guy you know these guys just drives
people uh-huh and i was just like who
you got i always ask them who they drove
because they always have like great
stories yo yeah he's going and he's like
i'll tell you who i drove won't believe
a couple months ago i drove bruce
springsteen
and i was go and i was just like going
oh my god what was that like he goes oh
god love him he just collapsed into the
car he was in so much pain after the
show he's almost 70. and he was sitting
that like talking about that's that's a
terrible i was like [ __ ] that's
pretty good that was like an irish uh
paul mccartney
um
he was talking about the what the guy
put through oh yeah physically that he
got in the car was like he was like
knees three hours yeah jumping up on the
piano there goes your hip jesus god god
love him um dude i've already seen it on
stephen stephen tyler's feet are all
[ __ ] up because you know that
galloping thing he does the way he would
tap his foot kind of on the side yeah
like he did just
the wear and tear and and uh
god james brown prince needing hip
replacements these guys like when those
people are [ __ ]
you know that's why they they're aside
from the talent like when they're
putting their bodies on the line like
that it's just like you can't even if
you're dumb you feel it and they expect
that if you go to a rolling stone show
you don't want mick jagger can't just
stand there you know what's amazing
about that guy is i think he weighs the
exact same weight he weighed when he did
the ed sullivan show yeah 64. it's just
like he's the same yeah he never got
like that you know that dad bod yeah
yeah he was hilarious he became a dad
yeah so 70s and he still doesn't have
dad but there's no excuse for any
anybody else out there yeah he's been a
dad like 12 times over yeah i said this
to you before i know you're not great
with compliments so i'm going to i'm not
going to yeah okay all right well thanks
for doing this pal and thanks f is for
families out now season 4. thank you for
crushing it for all of these years
we got season four's gonna be coming out
i don't know when early part of next
year or something i don't know yeah i
don't know it's still so fun to do uh
yeah i love where this the story is
going yes i'm trying to have fun because
it'll be sad when we stop i i know yeah
all right yeah so one of these days on
my podcast i got to get i got to get you
and you and sam let's do it okay all
right i can just do it before it's
bedtime all right all right
[Music]
one two three so
that happened
well that happened say that happened
it's strange for us because we listen to
him so you listen to him all the time
so it must be strange to hear my voice
occasionally like interject it's weird
in a way i'm like shut up like i in my
head i'm like just let him talk no i
thought that too that's why i don't
think i talked as much i say a lot of
yeah yeah yeah that's on brand yeah i
know i know i do too i can't it's hard
there's certain crutches that
whenever i listen to the show i like
gary cole in the office
i realize i have certain things that i
just say a lot i say the word so a lot
you do yeah yeah i say yeah a lot well
anyway something it's not about me it's
not about you yeah it's true it's about
something great it's gonna be great it's
about bill and uh
i i will say i think you did a good job
of and this is maybe going to sound
insulting to you but i think but i i
mean it as a compliment you'd i think
you did a really good job of
staying out of his way
to a large extent because
i don't think oh foam just fell down we
have a new little christian i have a new
little studio
in the house an in-home studio and it's
uh falling apart but um so maybe it
sounds a little different you listeners
yeah
but you but i
i think
his forte is just talking to himself i
do too you know that's clear i think
he's i think he's a good interview guest
i think he's good at interviewing people
but i think
definitely his forte is just being alone
yeah being a stand up yeah yeah
sometimes bill on bill's show if you're
not familiar with it he'll just be
listening
he'll be just watching a sports game and
it's entertaining that's the crazy thing
about his show is that he talks about
certain topics that i
have almost no interest in like
race car driving yeah race car drive
like gp uh motorcycle racing or
um aviation yeah or uh nhl hockey
there's certain things that a lot of
interest drumming yeah even things i'm
not interested in yeah i still want to
hear him talk about that's the mark of a
truly entertaining person he is maybe
the most entertaining single person that
i can think of he just has such strong
funny opinions that that's why i think
you just want to stay out of his way you
don't want to interfere too much you
want to let him get his opinions out in
the most efficient way possible as an
interviewer i think he's very convicted
and because of that it's it's almost not
worth
engaging on a in a back and forth i mean
maybe i'm making excuses for myself not
being able to also in your defense it
wasn't so much of a dialogue as some of
the other yeah interviews have been i
mean that's a nice taste of what his
show is about too it's basically like if
you listen back to the show and you mute
out every time
that's pretty much bill's show
and you add some hockey and yeah but
that's why it's so fun watching
listening to nia go on his wife because
she can actually she actually challenges
him right because she well knows him a
lot better than me but also is very
smart herself and quick and funny nia is
really really funny i never understood
or never appreciated that transactional
nature of stand-up comedy i never he
talks about that a bit yeah i know that
um when he feels it from the audience
yeah that that it's it's the audience
ideally gets to laugh yeah and gets
distracted from their own lives
um but the comedian
gets so much too they get so much
validation and the joy and the way you
feel i can imagine i can only imagine
uh when a whole audience full of people
are like laughing so hard they can't
breathe oh my god that feeling must be
unbelievable i i had that feeling when
it's only a handful of people when it's
one person it feels so good i mean that
i can't imagine well i think that way
about also
you know justin timberlake and people
like that who have
who just have control over a whole crowd
yeah but then you think what's the
opposite of that
what if you're alone on a stage i think
about that this is why stand-up comedy
to me is such a crazy thing to do
because
if you fail at that it must feel
horrible well that's why
i think bill burr got a lifetime's worth
of credit not just from comedians but
from
people like me fans of comedy for his
that rant that he delivered in that show
at that show in philadelphia um it's now
infamous
what are i guess famous now when does it
become famous isn't it
isn't it infamous when it's like a bad
thing
like uh lee harvey oswald is infamous
right that's true it's famous now it's
yeah i think it's a good thing it's a
good thing he he goes on a 12 minute
rant against philadelphia because these
people have been heckling his fellow
comedians all day and they've just been
such a rude volatile audience that he
just goes off on them and it is it's
like glorious that was my introduction
to bill burr you you uh that's right for
me um
but that feeling when you
are bombing on stage oh my god and
things aren't going well good i think
there always seems to be kind of a dark
undercurrent to these brilliant comedic
minds that that you meet that you come
across
and you ask him about that a little bit
you said you asked about the rivalries
and the jealousies yeah and i'm yeah
because it must be
i i can imagine how easy it would be to
be jealous of someone
um in that world because
if you're so desperate for laughs and so
afraid of the opposite of that
it makes sense that you would see people
doing well it'd be like i want well they
have and there's so few slots available
right the success for success like there
are
so many comedians trying to do that he
downplays that though he claims that
that's not much of a thing but i'm
really into like all these little like
in fights i mean
i'm really into this
that's such a comedy
uh i was thinking
about bill's um
special about tiger uh
tiger and
how some of the things he was saying
were so incendiary i mean like
especially in today's
cultural climate like um
that where it's it's quite easy to
offend and um he was saying such
potentially offensive things
but the audience was for the most part
as far as much as you could hear and
tell they were all laughing and enjoying
it and engaged so
it's almost like um
when you're performing live versus the
there are two different arenas that that
are being talked about when it comes to
that kind of comedy which is like one is
the people at home on twitter and social
media who have
you know have their phones at their
disposal and they can just say whatever
they want versus like the immediate
reaction of an audience and and how do
you
they're just different playing fields
and and
where does that comedy live where should
it live well he says that he's he had to
stay off social media exactly just to
avoid having reading something speaking
of the uh that feeling that feeling when
you are on stage and and you're just
experiencing this like sea of adulation
i remember
being on the side of the stage with my
ex
you know what i was gonna say no no i
just thought you were about to be like i
can relate to that oh no
[Laughter]
no no i can't really i
i mean the closest i can come is like
which i hate is bowing at the end of a
play which i [ __ ] hate doing i hate
the the bows i remember doing it once
uh i was doing a play in san diego and
and with hal linden who's the great and
donald faison and donald that's right we
talked about it uh
such a good guess but hal was 85 an old
school
actor great actor was on um barney
miller he played the lead in barney
miller if you remember that for some of
our
older more seasoned listeners um
and hal said and i was the director gave
me a note he said justin you're you got
to work on your bow
your bow was too like quick and like i
just wanted to get off the stage i hated
the idea of like um thank you and like
soaking up the apple and i said hi just
makes me uncomfortable to like bow and
and uh hal goes uh i'll take it i'll
take his bow
he like loved it he loved soaking it up
uh but i remember an ex i dated my
ex-girlfriend who was um
who was a musician and i remember being
on the side of that stage watching some
of those shows and the sea of like
like the way kevin smith talks about it
it's like love you know it's just like i
think more of it as like adulation and
she'd
the three of them was three people in
the band they'd walk off stage and
they'd be like oh where are we going to
eat now like where do you want to go for
dinner i i couldn't get over that there
was no sense of like their egos hadn't
didn't seem to be swollen or anything or
they weren't like
riding this wave of i'm sure you get
used to it or it lives in you somewhere
but yeah it didn't seem to i was always
so impressed by them like by their well
then it comes out in other ways yeah it
comes out everything comes out in the
wash that's true that's true i wonder
where uh
where bills come down um in the shower
yeah that's right i love that shouts out
i i do a version of that sometimes
shouting things out in the shower we're
not shouting them out but if i
like remembering something that you
regret or mine is more immediate mine is
more like if something i can't think of
a good example but if something
embarrassing happens like if you're at a
coffee shop and you and you
say something kind of weird embarrassing
or nerdy
and
uh and you walk away sometimes i'll be
like stupid yeah yeah i'll like whisper
to myself like
i'll like make a noise like because you
just want to like yeah what are you
gonna talk to myself about like doing a
dumb move in traffic like what are you
doing yeah yeah
one of the best parts of his podcast is
how much he
is how much he protests about not being
an alcoholic
yes for for someone who claims to not
being out to not be an alcoholic he
talks about not being an alcoholic so
much
that but i i know what he's saying like
you get on these streaks where you don't
want to
[Music]
you want to like challenge yourself
because it's so easy to get in certain
routines and he
is such a
such a uh
he throws himself into whatever he's
doing so aggressively i think as a
person he's so committed so committed
yeah and he has so many hobbies he he uh
he's so well-rounded you know you talked
about the drumming and the and the
aviation he does so many things
but one of the things
the downside of doing so many things and
and uh being so versatile i think
is
when you get really into an unhealthy
thing like drinking
um then you have to sort of challenge
yourself to to you know he's taking time
off but i do that too i i
try to take certain days off to just to
prove to myself that i'm not an
alcoholic see bill's one of those people
that's so convicted and makes such
uh compelling arguments for things and
we listen to him a lot i think he's had
a tremendous like impact on our lives i
think i wonder
in other words i wonder if you would
are you more like bill
now do you like bill because you're more
like you're like him or
are you more like bill because you like
the question chicken or the egg yeah
i wonder because you've been listening
to him for a long time yeah and he's so
good at like self-management bill is
very like i'm gonna take a month like
you said i mean disciplined he's very
disciplined yeah yeah because he has to
be he would say because he has to
because otherwise he would spiral out of
control that's true but it's still a
very impressive
quality i think to be able to rein
yourself in like that yeah i love that
story he told about nia and their
their second date and not wanting to go
back to bar because it's like that's
their place oh my god that's so it's
funny when someone who's so um
just kind of
tough and i know it's kind of like he's
got this like boston he's so masculine
yeah so when a guy like that says
something romantic about his wife it's
it seems so much more romantic i know
because it's it's
honest yeah and it doesn't come from
this place it's not performant
performative you know yeah i love their
relationship they're so great together
i've seen guys perform on like so you
see it a lot on social media um
this what this human when i met her two
and a half years ago my world changed
you know and they go on these long
screeds about every little thing they
like about the person yeah it's about a
little place they go together yes
yeah oh you go shopping at trader joe's
together like
you know and and they make it this
this profound romantic experience
performance it's for other exactly that
was not for anybody
exactly that just slipped out he was
like i just like these yeah that's how
you know it's really that's truly
romantic when it's like
when it's almost embarrassing after
you've said it he was like if anything
he was like oh yeah you know that's it
don't he's not proud of it yeah he's not
shining a light on it it's the opposite
of those social media screeds where
people have to write all these little
things they do with their significant
other to show everybody you know before
the interview started i was a little
nervous about one specific thing weirdly
which was
how are you going to ask bill burr about
the muppets i i know i pictured him
i'm not kidding i pictured him being
like
the [ __ ] muppets
yeah i know well that's why i had the
way i said grown man i i thought you
might be shamed for that question
who would have thought that's why i said
it like that yeah
you you dipped your toe in yeah and i
tried to say it like a tough guy way i
was like so i gotta ask you about that
who's
[Laughter]
who would have thought that he
you could have done a whole show about
this oh my god and he's got excitement
about it
i know i love him i love him that that
like solidified how i feel about him and
he made such a good case for different
muppets yeah which again he's so
convicted yeah i don't know why i was
scared that he would react that way and
he's so smart it's bill's like a classic
example of somebody who maybe wasn't
like formerly educated didn't go to
harvard or yale but like has such a
brilliant mind and it's actually the
best combination to have it's somebody
who like
is doesn't maybe know you know fancy
that many fancy words sometimes trips
over like some pretentious word and is
like honest about it but it has such a
brilliant mind it's like i've no i've
known the opposite of that i've known
people who were like smart and like
really indulged in how smart they were
and like used big you know we all have
seen examples of that another reason to
listen to his podcast is
he really makes the most out of each day
yeah and and
that's kind of the premise of the show
is trying to figure out um where these
people how these people fill up their
days and how they make the most out of
their lives and i i think it's
it's very safe to say that he makes the
most out of his life he's um
you know he he's very active he does it
now as a father he seems like such a
great father you can tell just just the
snippets that uh you you hear on his
podcast um he just seems like he really
is engaged in his daughter's life and he
seems to really love life yes yes
despite his bad temper isn't that
interesting that's the thing he has a
really bad temper but he also seems to
really love life yeah but if you met
that guy usually it's funny like 95 of
the time when he's like ranting about
something or something like sets him off
or he's triggered i kind of agree with
him maybe that's why i like him yes we i
i see where he's coming from and
oftentimes it's just simple uh etiquette
you know social etiquette it's it's the
things that seinfeld points points out
and the other grey comedians he just
does it in the maybe slightly more
aggressive yes yes should we read a
letter yeah
this is a letter from ashton
p
uh and the subject is hey you
through hey yo
oh it is oh
h-e-y-y-y-o-o-o heyo
dear justin i'm 20 years old lucky
he didn't say that and i am in my junior
year of college that's great i
previously attended a community college
for two years and i just recently
transferred to a university to which i
am i now have a commute of about an hour
more or less
sorry i butchered that in efforts to not
be on my phone while driving i took up
listening to podcast it started with
armchair expert then i quickly
discovered life is short
as a student nearing the end of my
education my thoughts are constantly
filled with worry about my future the
anxiety can keep me up at night clearly
as i type this at 2 am
and it also hinders my ability to be
proactive productive
i sometimes wish i could skip all the
hard stuff and move to the part in my
life where i have a job and i am
successful when i listen to your podcast
i've heard you say you wished you could
have been more mindful of appreciating
the process in the beginning of your
career so that's what i've been trying
to practice to realize where i'm at
right now is good and appreciating each
day each and every day as is
not every day is a victory but i'm doing
better thanks to you because even though
it doesn't feel like it right now life
is short sincerely ashton side note i
love the so that just happened
yeah thanks ashton
so that just happened part of the
podcast you and christian are a great
duo who always makes me laugh that's
awesome thank you uh that is very very
nice and it's funny we were just talking
about that uh in terms of making the
most it's like that's appreciating life
that reminds me of that scene and billy
madison when
when the kid is like i want to grow yeah
yeah yeah adult like you billy and he
grabs
that's how we feel about ashton right
now young forever don't skip the
quote-unquote hard part ashton because
right now yeah don't make it harder than
it is that's what i would say you don't
grow up i remember being that age i
remember being younger and straight and
i know you can relate to this stressing
about oh my god a test that you have or
what grade you got in some class or what
a waste how much value and pressure you
put on that i know and it is
looking back on that it's like why i
wish i could have just
enjoy the enjoy what you're learning for
sure but yes don't stress about the
grades you're getting i would have
enjoyed what i was learning more if i
hadn't been so preoccupied of you know
the paper i had to write or the grade i
was going to be given for like
regurgitating that information i but but
as i say this i now i realize how futile
futile that might be because i remember
when people would say versions of that
to me when i was that age and it doesn't
you have to focus on deaf ears i know
you just have to
i guarantee you ashton in 20 years
you're going to look back on this letter
and roll your eyes to yourself and be
like i wish i
i just enjoyed that a little bit or
maybe you can maybe not but maybe it
sounds like he's very ashen's very like
conscientious of that and which i don't
think i was at the time of
appreciating
moments of life and appreciating life
and your youth well i think if you are
able to get through to ashton and
convince him that he should be enjoying
this time in his life really good thing
then this podcast has done its job
because that is even for one person to
redirect their way of thinking i think
that's really nice yeah oh that's that's
really nice and i would yeah i wish i
had someone had impressed that upon me
when i was that age and the cynic in me
wants to say ashton it's all downhill
from here really enjoy it now because
because the hard part is not 20 years
from now but i know but i can relate to
him i remember that feeling well uh
thanks ashton for writing and if you
guys want to write in it's
uh our email is life is short at
wondery.com and we would very much like
to hear from you
yeah and uh thanks to ashton thanks to
bill justin just uh spaced out for a
second sorry i'm so hungry thanks to
bill uh for being on the show and for
being a great comedian and having a
great podcast everyone check it people
don't uh abandon this podcast to listen
to fully but i would recommend adding it
to your podcast lineup yes it's called
the monday morning podcast and thanks to
everyone
life could be a dream
life could
thanks for listening to life short
justin long is your host and christian
is uh your co-host my co-host and your
co-and producer oh boy
life is short is also produced by megan
monaco our senior producer is michelle
miche lans audio engineer is marcelino
villapando executive producers are
marcia louis and annan lopez for wonder
that's the worst we've ever done it yeah
but i hope you guys forgive us and we'll
see you next week
[Music]
[Music]
yes
boston boston boston boston born and
raised in boston i'm born and raised i'm
born and raised born born it's born born
and raised because they almost go for
the ar but then they miss it born and
raised a lot of people say bond but it's
not it's really born born born born not
don't go
a little bit